east falgos bonjour vous êtes
chroniqueur internationale pour france24
pas de mobilisation générale donc
annoncé par vladimir poutine ce matin
dans son discours le président russe qui
on l'a entendu justifie à nouveau sa
guerre en ukraine saas etc pour
justifier son opération spéciale auprès
de l'opinion publique russe oui oui et
puis pas d'annoncé majeure sur la
rhétorique aujourd'hui elle est bien
connue en fait en tout cas depuis
plusieurs semaines à nouveau la russie
et l'agressé l'occident et l'agresseur
selon lui les autorités ukrainiennes
préparer une attaque contre les
séparatistes pro russes dans le combat
ça laisse du pays il voulait se doter de
la bombe atomique
il voulait se rapprocher ou adhérer à
l'otan la grande terreur de vladimir
poutine est finalement l'armée russe
selon lui n'a agi que par riposte par
riposte d'anticipation ce sont ce sont
ses termes afin une riposte préventive
pourraient plus exact afin d'éviter une
nouvelle guerre mondiale et puis bien
sûr il ya toujours cette analogie qu'ils
aiment faire entre la victoire
soviétique contre le nazisme en 1945 et
cette croisade qu'il mène en ukraine
pour une dénazification du pays ce sont
ses termes maintenant depuis plusieurs
années pour le reste les principales
craintes et vous venez de l'évoquer des
observateurs occidentaux
internationaux n'ont pas été confirmées
pas de déclarations d'annexion de de
pardon du dombass et notamment des
territoires séparatistes dont basse par
la russie pour l'instant la russie ne
reconnaît que leur indépendance pas
d'escaladé non plus dans le discours sur
la menace nucléaire et surtout pas de
déclarations effectivement formelle de
guerre contre l'ukraine qui aurait fait
basculer le conflit dans une autre
dimension avec la possibilité notamment
de recruter ou de faire appel à des
conscrits de déclarer la mobilisation
générale de fait rappelle également aux
alliés de la russie c'est quelque chose
qui politiquement très risquée puisque
déclarer la guerre ça veut dire qu'on
rencontre des difficultés sur le terrain
ça oblige aussi les russes à aller
combattre et on n'est pas sûr que les
russes partent la fleur au fusil sur le
front est donc pour l'instant rien de
tout ça n'a été en tout cas confirmés
par vladimir poutine aujourd'hui et puis
pad annonces de victoire non plus un nom
de vladimir poutine parce que sur sur le
terrain l'armée russe elle patine ah oui
alors vous théoriquement entassons
c'était très compliqué de présenter une
victoire vladimir poutine ne peut se
prévaloir
donc une conquête majeure en tout cas
dans les grandes villes sur le terrain
certes on va peut-être le voir sur la
carte là mais russes contrôlent
aujourd'hui cette fameuse bande qui la
relie qui relie le territoire russe à
l'est de l'ukraine vers la crimée
qu'elle a annexé en 2014 mais on est
très loin des objectifs que s'est fixés
le président poutine au début de
l'offensive dans le don baril alors
voilà cardon basse juste derrière moi
les villes par exemple comme sylvie
rodeau n'est ce coup cramatte or ce que
ne sont pas tombés l'armée piétine
marioupol marioupol dont on parle
maintenant depuis des semaines même si
elle est quasiment sous contrôle russe
il ya toujours cette poche de résistance
du bataillon un oeuf dans l'usinage of
talent donc il ne peut même pas se
prévaloir même s'il l'a fait mais d'une
victoire totale à marioupol les
ukrainiens se sont même permis des
contre attaques du côté de kharkiv par
exemple où il ya des portions du
territoire qui était sous contrôle russe
qui ont été repris par les ukrainiens du
côté de carson également l'ukraine
l'armée la russie pardon n'a toujours
pas le contrôle désert bref poutine
s'est bien gardé d'annoncer ce lundi une
quelconque victoire mais aussi de fixer
des objectifs concrets avec un
calendrier dans ce qu'il appelle
effectivement toujours son opération
spéciale en russie merci beaucoup en
ukraine merci beaucoup baptiste